bassem bonsoir alors l'autorité
nationale indépendante à des élections a
donc annoncé enfin on va dire les
résultats à des législatives anticipées
en algérie bonjour samantha
effectivement il aura fallu attendre
trois jours pour que l'autorité
nationale indépendante des élections
annonce ses résultats des législatives
un scrutin qui a été no tô nos largement
boycottées par les algériens notamment
par l'opposition et par le mouvement du
ra qui avait appelé à boycotter ces
élections alors que les pro gouvernement
avait appelé à voter massivement pousser
les élections législatives
vous aurez été annoncée le taux de
participation de 23 3%
c'est largement en dessous des dernières
législatives de 2007 avec un taux de
participation de 35,79 c'est à 18h30
heure locale à alger que autorités à
annoncer ces élections
ils ont annoncé bien sûr le fln sans
aucune surprise vainqueur de ces
élections législatives avec 105 sièges
suivi des indépendances a été un petit
peu la surprise de ces élections
législatives des indépendants qui ont pu
gagner 78 sièges pour ces législatives
78 sièges au parlement à partir de
demain bien sûr s'ouvrira à la cession
des recours donc les partis politiques
pourront poser reposer des recours pour
contester le résultat de ces élections
législatives
et puis à noter bien sûr contrairement à
ce que prévoyait la loi électorale sur
la parité hommes femmes au parlement
huit véhicules 34% seulement deux femmes
seront représentés dans ce parlement
algérien c'est bien en dessous de ce
qu'espérait le gouvernement algérien
surtout ce que prévoyait la loi
électorale une participation qui n'a pas
été à importante les algériens se sont
rendus aux urnes au compte gouttes en
plein en pleine période de contestation
il faut le dire en algérie ça fait
maintenant deux ans que beaucoup
d'algériens battent le pavé sur
l'ensemble du territoire pour contester
bien sûr la politique menée par le
gouvernement et demande la refonte du
système politique algérien
c'est ce qui a été impulsée notamment ça
avait été commencé à deux ans avec la
contestation d'un cinquième mandat
du président abdelaziz bouteflika qui
avait donné lieu à des élections
présidentielles qui ont vu vainqueur le
président a dit magyd tebboune et puis à
l'issue de sa bien sûr le nouveau
président avait demandé des élections
législatives anticipées ce qu'il faut
retenir de ces élections légistatives
qu'on a pu suivre
ag c'est que les bureaux de vote
n'étaient pas remplies les algériens ont
largement boudé la sélection avec
quelques difficultés complications en
kabylie au nord du pays notamment dans
les villes de bedjaïa de tizi ouzou où
la participation était moins de 1% c'est
vous dire que les algériens ont
largement boycotté quand même ces
élections des résultats ont tardé à
arriver puis bien sûr à partir de demain
on pourra avoir certaines contestations
de la part de certains partis politiques
et le conseil constitutionnel de son
côté a dix jours pour valider
définitivement les résultats de ces
élections législatives
merci beaucoup à vous bassem h he be
pour toutes ces informations et vous
êtes de retour donc à tunis vous avez
couvert ces élections législatives
anticipées à alger pour nous